The diver screams a silent scream as the giant
squid’s beak digs into his skin, its many
grasping tentacles grabbing him and holding
him in place.
Nearby, his fellow divers are driven half-mad
with terror as they see mysterious figures
floating towards them through the murk - And
strange, Russian voices speaking in their
heads.
Nobody can help them.
They’re down too deep, too consumed by the
darkness and the pressure of the sea.
They’re now at the mercy of whatever is
inside the submarine…
Beginning in the 1940s with the dawn of nuclear
weapons, the American government conducting
the world’s first atomic weapons test, and
the Soviet Union responding in kind with nuclear
testing of their own, the two powers entered
an arms race fueled by rivalry and a thirst
to prove their strength on the world stage.
What followed were decades of staggering technological
advancements as each nation tried to outdo
and intimidate the other.
The Soviet Union crossed into the cold reaches
of outer space, deploying the satellite Sputnik.
The United States responded with the founding
of NASA.
Tensions reached a fever pitch during the
Cuban Missile Crisis of 1962, as United States
citizens feared they were teetering on the
brink of nuclear war.
In July of 1968, the Soviet Union, the United
Kingdom, and the United States came together
to sign the Treaty on the Nonproliferation
of Nuclear Weapons, agreeing to abandon their
pursuit of increased nuclear power and turn
their focus to disarmament.
But several months before the treaty was signed,
the Soviet government was dealing in weaponry
far more dangerous than nuclear missiles,
something the other world powers knew nothing
about.
These deadly secrets were hidden aboard a
submarine known as SCP-741.
SCP-741 is the underwater wreckage of a Soviet
submarine that sank in March 1968 and came
into the custody of the SCP Foundation in
1999.
The submarine, a version of the Charlie II
class, was deployed under unusual circumstances,
which attracted the attention of the United
States government.
In an attempt to learn more about the submarine,
the US Government launched Project [Redacted],
which attempted to recover the vessel from
the ocean in the early 1970s.
They managed to recover a few pieces of the
vessel, though the specifics are highly classified.
In the late 1990s, the US Government contacted
the SCP Foundation, informing them of a possible
Euclid or Keter-class anomaly in the wreck.
At this point, it passed into the custody,
and surveillance, of the Foundation.
The submarine is on the ocean floor, broken
into three pieces.
The hull was broken into bits during the Project
[Redacted] recovery attempt but was largely
intact when it first sank except for two holes,
one just in front of the sail and one just
below the starboard missile tubes.
Apparently, the vessel sank rapidly due to
flooding after an enemy missile strike, which
occurred while it was surfacing.
Though all parts of the submarine are accounted
for, no members of the crew have been located.
Additionally, none of the emergency escape
equipment onboard has been used, raising further
questions about what became of the crew.
Wherever they went, they seem to have left
something behind.
Whenever divers are sent down to investigate
the wreckage, they report experiencing anomalous
currents and strange sea life, and hearing
moans, disembodied voices, and incoherent
whispering.
They also report seeing blurry, faintly glowing
figures.
Additionally, the ocean life in the area is
unnaturally aggressive, particularly large
squid and sharks.
This effect was first noted during a manned
expedition into the waters around the wreckage,
described in Incident Report I741-A.
Divers A26 through A30 embarked from the icebreaker
Yamal into the waters below with the intention
of studying the potential anomalous activity
surrounding the wreckage.
As the group of divers approached the submarine,
they could feel the shift in the water around
them, the oppressive feeling of abnormally
increased pressure bearing down and threatening
to crush them.
If their specialized diving equipment were
to fail, they know that that would be it,
and the command would have to come and fish
their corpses out of the water.
Or, even worse, they could vanish entirely,
meeting the same mysterious fate as the crew
of that doomed submarine.
But they couldn't fixate on that.
They had a job to do.
At first glance, the wreckage appeared undisturbed,
unchanged since the previous inspection.
Still, they needed to take a closer look to
be sure.
As the team got closer to the vessel, A30
was startled by the sight of movement from
within the wreckage, spotting motion through
one of the holes in the structure as something
passed by.
He pointed it out to his colleagues, but they
dismissed this as likely a giant isopod or
spider crab, which were crawling all over
the surrounding area.
A30 laughed off his jumpiness, agreed that
they were probably right, and continued the
exploration as planned.
Control authorized the divers to proceed to
the next step, and A29 activated sonar and
lights, moving toward the starboard-side breach.
There, a faint glowing caught his eye.
The glow resembled that of radioactive material,
but when the team checked the radiation levels
in the area, they remained stable.
Whatever the source of the glow was, it wasn’t
radioactive.
At this point, his neutron counter began to
register something, and all of a sudden, a
disembodied voice could be heard saying, "Vasily,
Yevgeny, can you hear me?"
The voice was muffled, and though it could
be heard over their communication channels,
it emanated from somewhere in the wreckage.
Deep, deep underwater.
As A29 watched, a glowing shape emerged from
the darkness.
It was only an outline, the suggestion of
a silhouette, but the shape was undeniably
familiar.
It looked like a person.
The other divers quickly noticed the apparition
too and began to panic.
Some checked their nitrogen levels, believing
it to be some sort of nitrogen narcosis, while
others pointed out that they couldn’t all
be suffering from nitrogen narcosis at the
same time.
The unknown voice continued speaking, saying
"Help me, it's getting hard to breathe."
The divers debated what to do next, questioning
whether what they were seeing was even real,
when all at once, the humanoid figure vanished
from sight.
The divers attempted to shake off the startling
encounter, and they resumed their duties,
the investigation proceeding as normal.
After a few moments of uneventful work, another
interruption presented itself in the form
of a five-meter-long squid swimming around
the wreckage.
Its presence startled the divers at first,
particularly those closest to the animal,
but the others encouraged them to ignore it,
citing the fact that there are no records
of these squid attacking humans.
So they did, continuing their work as the
squid circled them with apparent curiosity.
A27 spotted an unusual shell below the wreckage,
notably large and difficult to identify and
control requested that they bring it up to
the surface for further inspection by a marine
biologist.
The divers began attaching haul cables to
the shell as the squid crept closer and closer.
All of a sudden, A26 screamed, and there was
a sudden bloom of blood in the water.
The squid, despite it being uncharacteristic
behavior for its species, attacked the diver,
biting him savagely.
Prompted by cries for help from the diving
team, control began to reel A26 back toward
the surface, proceeding slowly to give him
decompression time, and the squid took advantage
of the slow retreat.
It chased after the diver, grabbing hold of
him and biting down again, tearing away at
him as it gripped him in its tentacles.
Still, Control continued reeling him in, hoping
to free him from the squid’s grasp as they
yanked him to the surface.
The other divers were ordered to get themselves
out of there as fast as possible, an order
they gladly obeyed.
As they swam back to the surface, A30 saw
something else moving in the depths.
He couldn't make out what it was, but the
sight of it gave him a sick feeling of dread
deep in the pit of his stomach.
The four divers were recovered alive, along
with the shell.
Examination of the shell indicated that it
resembled that of the extinct orthoconic nautiloids,
but it was not fossilized.
It was taken for further study, given the
possible implication of extinct species anomalously
manifesting in the vicinity of SCP-714.
Diver A26 lost a limb, and was exposed to
an unknown venom via bites from the attacking
squid.
His camera was destroyed in the process.
As squid are not known to attack humans unprovoked,
this behavior has been attributed to the influence
of SCP-741, though the exact link between
the two is yet to be determined.
An anomalous pressure gradient surrounds the
wreck with a radius of approximately 250m,
starting around the center of the submarine.
The pressure in this area is much greater
than it should be, given the depth of the
waters there.
This unusually high pressure makes sonar analysis
extremely difficult, as well as threatening
the safety of any divers in the vicinity of
the wreck.
The few records that the Foundation has managed
to obtain from the Russian and U.S. governments
indicate that the submarine was being used
to transport some sort of secret cargo.
Though the specifics of this cargo are still
unknown, there is reason to believe that it
differed from any type of nuclear or chemical
weaponry.
On a date redacted from official files, the
SCPS Basisty was patrolling the area around
SCP-741 when its sonar detected some unknown
entity approaching SCP-741 from the South
at a pace of 46 knots.
The crew compared the acoustic signature of
the contact with known submarines and torpedoes
but could not find a match.
The Basisty attempted to reach the contact
via sonobuoy drops and active sonar pings,
but it did not respond.
When the contact crossed into the total underwater
exclusion zone, it became classified as hostile.
At that point, the Sonar recorded sounds of
an undersea missile launch, and Basisty responded
with the utmost urgency.
The ship broke away from its original area
and fired a Type 53 torpedo at the underwater
threat.
Fifteen seconds after the Basisty launched
its torpedo, missiles of an unidentified configuration
were seen breaking the water, flying at a
height of 1.8 meters and a velocity of 0.92
Mach.
The missiles did not emit any detectable radar,
nor did they respond to any launched chaff
or flares from the Basisty.
Both of the missiles were engaged by Basisty's
3K95 Kinzhal surface-to-air missiles and Kashtan
point defense systems, and were destroyed
at 1800 meters and 210 meters from impact,
respectively.
After the missiles were neutralized, the hostile
vessel could be heard engaging in evasive
maneuvers.
At this point , there were four closely-spaced
explosions, and the sound of a submarine disintegrating.
The identity of the attacker, as well as its
intentions toward SCP-741, have not yet been
determined.
The incident resulted in the Foundation research
team suggesting an expansion of the acoustic
sensor net, as well as additional patrol and
defense assets placed in the area.
Additionally, they advised an acquisition
of undersea retaliatory capability.
The incident was classified Incident I741-C.
The sonar recordings from the SCPS Basisty
during Incident I741-C were taken for further
analysis by the research team.
The in-depth review revealed anomalous acoustic
signatures that did not match up with any
known forms of propulsion, including magnetohydrodynamic
drive.
Currently, the nature of the unidentified
attacker remains a mystery, and it has not
been attributed to any particular government
or organization.
Following the incident involving the SCPS
Basisty, an American intelligence agent reached
out to the Foundation, offering further insight
into the secretive government programs looking
into SCP-741.
He agreed to sit for an interview with a Foundation
researcher assigned to the project, on the
condition that his identity remain protected.
The SCP Researcher's name is absent from the
official file as well.
The two men sat in a Foundation interview
room, and the interviewer asked his informant
why he chose to come forward, given the US
Government had simply chosen to sit on this
information for 30 years.
"You've seen those reports - Project [REDACTED].
We knew that part, too.
How the directors didn't make the connection
is beyond me.
That, and the stuff the [Redacted] pulled
up?
Yeah.
The other part you don't hear about is what
some of the research team died of.
And the crewmen we buried?
Just uniforms.
Also, the nuclear device we recovered wasn't
a missile or torpedo warhead, it was a demolition
charge.
Does that make any sense?
After all those clues, I had to come forward.
Why the directorate didn't is something I
can't fully explain."
This particular statement puzzled the Foundation
Researcher, raising questions he hadn't anticipated.
Only uniforms?
Did this mean that the sub had been unmanned?
The informant replied, "No, not unmanned.
There were no bodies, but personal effects
were everywhere, along with uniforms.
There was some blood - human, before you ask
- on one of the torpedoes and a bit of skin,
where somebody probably crushed his hand loading
the thing.
Just, no bodies left.
When I first looked into all this, I had no
clue what the hell had gone on down there,
but I started putting things together."
The Foundation Agent began to speculate based
on the mounting evidence.
Could it have been a Soviet Weapons Program?
A deadly biological agent of some kind?
"No, no, it wasn't that.
I thought maybe it could have been, so I dialed
up some of my contacts at Biopreparat - us
spies wind up owing each other favors after
a while - and they denied it.
Vehemently.
Not your usual cover-up baloney, either; they
clearly stated that whatever the sub was carrying,
it wasn't theirs, and they wanted no part
of it.
Sounded like he was gonna puke when I mentioned
[REDACTED].
And Doctor, do you have any idea what it takes
to make a bioweapons researcher sick?"
Now, that wasn't what really bugged me, though.
What really kept me awake at night was the
KGB files that fell into our hands.
They mentioned a covert op by the Soviet military
against an internal, unnamed faction, to get
rid of "terrifying weapons" that "even the
Soviet Union can't safely control".
They wanted to lose it, whatever it was, or
maybe fob it off onto the US.
Of course, that all came to light right before
the Iron Curtain fell, and given the atmosphere
at the time, it was practically impossible
to convince the directors that they weren't
talking about nukes, and even once I did,
they still didn't think this was worthy of
action.
I mean, the [REDACTED] will probably have
me hanged for treason if they ever find me,
but it was worth the risk.
And by what I can gather, it sounds like Russia
thinks so too - loaning you half the Pacific
Fleet, and all…"
The interview continued after this point,
but the rest of the conversation was considered
irrelevant and stricken from the official
file.
The interview left the Foundation with more
questions than answers, though they were more
certain than ever that SCP-741 must be kept
under strict containment procedures.
Due to the object's location at the bottom
of the sea, as well as the unusually elevated
pressure around it, it is unlikely that many
civilians will come into contact with it.
However, as an extra protective measure, sonar
and submersible monitoring is conducted on
a periodic basis in order to verify that the
wreckage has not been interfered with in any
way.
The Foundation-contracted Russian warships,
SCPS Basisty and Krasnoyarsk, have been selected
for this purpose.
If any unauthorized activity occurs in the
area surrounding SCP-741, nuclear and conventional
missiles may be deployed.
Any movement of SCP-741 is grounds for an
immediate nuclear strike.
Whatever secrets SCP-741 holds, whatever it
was transporting that was even more of an
uncontrollable threat than nuclear warfare,
they're better left alone down there at the
bottom of the sea.
Now check out “SCP-2316 - The Bodies in
the Water” and “SCP-054 - Water Nymph”
for more!